i would have gone in earlier
and you know would have been
hopefully caught earlier friends star
james michael tyler
is sharing his heartbreaking health
struggles
my goal this past year
was to see my 59th birthday the actor
who is best known for playing gunther on
friends
and there's nobody to hug
sat down with the today show and
revealed the reason why he appeared
virtually on the friends reunion special
that dropped on hbo max
last month i'm sorry to say that i'm
not appearing today with you to announce
that there's going to be a friends movie
[Music]
actually i'm here to let you know that
in september of 2018
i was diagnosed with uh advanced to
prostate
cancer which had spread to my bones
the 59 year old actor also goes on to
share that the cancer was caught during
a routine physical exam
and unfortunately was already at stage
four by the time of his
prostate-specific
antigen test so
eventually you know it's going to
probably get me james also says that the
reason he appeared virtually during the
friends reunion was because he didn't
want to ruin a joyous moment
when's your birthday may 5th why oh i
i'm just making a list of people's
birthdays
oh mine's december yeah whatever ladies
and gentlemen james michael tyler
gander himself that was a celebration of
25 years
you know i didn't want to be like oh and
by the way gunther has cancer
you know what i mean the actor also
tearfully admits that his biggest regret
is not listening to his wife jennifer
and going to the doctor sooner
now he says his goal is to save at least
one life
next time you go in for just a basic
exam or
your yearly checkup please ask your
doctor for a psa test my goal this past
year
was to see my 59th birthday
i did that james revealed that since his
diagnosis
his friend's family has reached out to
him including
david schwimmer i just have to tell you
i love you
and when e.t spoke with james in 2002
he opened up about how close he and the
friends cast have become
over the years it's hard to get through
a day sometimes i mean because people
are
they forget okay we gotta get to work
now you know let's stop joking around so
but yeah i mean we still have a lot of
fun
you